nous sommes en plein coeur de la région
reculée d'araucanie au sud-est du chili
le peuple mapuches en marche pour écrire
une nouvelle page de son histoire ses
citoyens autochtones appellent à plus de
considération et rêve d'une vie
meilleure
c'est l'occasion pour nous
les mapuches d'avoir la possibilité
d'être réellement écouté
l'afrique est d'être enfin reconnu pour
ce que notre peuple était et est encore
[Musique]
17 sièges de la nouvelle assemblée
seront réservés aux 10 peuples
autochtones chilien au total 155 membres
seront missionné pour écrire une
nouvelle constitution dans un délai de
neuf mois la dernière rédigé et imposer
sous la dictature militaire du général
augusto pinochet de 1973 à 1990
ce week end du 15 et 16 mai les chiliens
étaient donc attendus dans les bureaux
de vote après une année et demie de
contestation dans les rues et sur les
réseaux sociaux protestation contre les
frais de taxi les retraites les soins de
santé ou encore la pauvreté des écoles
et pourtant selon les premières
estimations seulement entre 35 et 40% de
la population s'est rendue aux urnes
entre méfiance politique inquiétudes
entourant la crise sanitaire et espoir
tout de même
j'espère un chili plus juste et plus
ordonnée
[Musique]
j'espère que le pays pourra reprendre sa
croissance économique mais aussi que
nous pourrons réduire considérablement
les inégalités sociales nous avons une
grande offre en dehors de tout pacte
politique des pactes politique que nous
avions l'habitude de voir sur le
bulletin de vote
aujourd'hui nous voyons de nouvelles
personnes de nouveaux visages sur les
bulletins de vote
auteur écrivain professeur travailleurs
sociaux avocats semblent être les grands
gagnants de ces élections
lundi matin après plus de 90% des
dépouillements plus de 50% des partis
indépendants arrive ainsi en tête suivi
de l'opposition de gauche à plus de 30%
cette dernière défenseurs notamment des
droits sociaux la nouvelle constitution
doit être votée en 2022 par un
référendum
autre grand sainement avec un peu plus
de 20% les candidats de la droite au
pouvoir regrouper sur une seule grande
liste sont sanctionnés une mauvaise
nouvelle pour le président milliardaire
sebastian pinera
à six mois des élections présidentielles